Build tools aren't a new thing, but
web test specific build tools only
became popular a few years ago.
The most simple build tool is
just a shell, or bash script.
These scripts, with the .sh extension,
are just a series of terminal commands
or functions, and
can be executed from the command line.
But working with the Penzi graphs, or
only updating files that have changed
are tricky tasks with just a shell.
And this is where
the original build system,
make, comes in,
adding file management, and more.
After make came build tools such as Ant,
Maven, and
Gradle, all especially
popular in the world of Java.
All of them have declarative tasks.
But you need to use XML to drive them,
or
in the case of Gradle, a programming
language that you might not understand.
But web developers
have a burning hate for
everything XML, with the only exception
of HML as an accepted flavor.
And so came a new set of modern web
development focused build tools.
Tools that would use a language that web
developers are already familiar with,
JavaScript.
Out of the JavaScript are node
JS based build tools,
two have become very popular,
Grunt and Gulp.
But why are these the popular ones and
what should you look for
in a build tool?
I thought you'd never ask.
A build tool should be fast in
execution as there's need for
speed when iterating on a website or
app.
We're used to changing a line or
reloading a page afterwards to see
the changes instantly and
disrupting that flow is a no go.
It should also be supported by a healthy
community that exchanges plugins that
add functionality and answers questions
on sites such as Stack Overflow.
With popular build tools such as Grunt,
chances are there's already
an answer to your problem, and
somebody else has had it before.
Next, it's very important that even
if it comes with a lot of bells and
whistles you can extend it with more and
custom functionality as you see fit.
And finally, the tool should at best
already solve a few common problems
out of the box for it to be useful.
Grunt, the currently most popular tool,
fulfills many of these requirements.
It has a strong community and
a healthy plugin ecosystem.
But Gulp,
the new popular kid on the block,
has two significant
advantages over Grunt.
It's built for speed and
can execute tasks in parallel,
plus converts open files into
super fast streams internally.
Gulp's task, use code over
configuration, which means that you can
just use normal JavaScript, and extend
or modify tasks that don't work for you.
You might have already guessed it,
we're sticking with Gulp for
the rest of this course.
But if your team or
company chooses Grunt or
a different system instead, fear not.
Usually the concept of what work is done
in all of them is quite similar, and
many times the plugin exists for both.